- Thank you.
- I love this outfit.
- Thank you so much.
- I am not kidding.
I am that person that I, if you,
it's almost like a it's a bad thing,
because if you come on,
if I happen to like
scroll through something
and I see you, I'm like, oh,
and then I see you and
I watch the whole thing.
- You're so sweet.
- Even if I've seen it.
- That's so sweet.
- I've seen
The Princess Switch with my
daughter I don't know how many
and alone, not just 'cause my daughter.
I love them.
- Well, let me love
on you for a second.
- Oh, okay.
- So when I was coming, I
grew up like doing theater
and like
- Yeah, me too.
- this has always been a passion of mine
and you were on American Idol and you won.
And I was like, that's it,
I'm going on American Idol.
- What?
- And then that next week
I got an audition for High School Musical
and booked it.
- Well, that worked out.
- So then I was like,
well, never mind, but.
(audience cheering)
- That worked out.
- I was like, I'm doing it
and you were the catalyst.
- Oh, I love that!
- Yeah.
- That is so funny.
You are though, you're captivating.
There's only like a few
people, honestly, in my world
like of entertainment
that I'm like, must watch.
I can't turn it off.
I don't why.
- You're so sweet.
- But it's been 16 years
since High School Musical.
Do you remember the beginning of that?
- 'Cause that was your
- I mean.
- big first thing.
- Yeah,
like remember all the auditions
definitely.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause there were a lot of them.
- Oh really?
Oh.
- Yeah.
There were, I mean there were like three,
- but like I remember--
- You know the same thing with Idol.
People don't know that,
but there were many auditions
- Yeah.
- before even got
to the TV part.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- I like remember meeting
Zac for the first time,
meeting Lucas for the first time.
- Oh wow.
- Me and Ashley
had already met
'cause we did a commercial
together like a month prior so.
- Random.
- Yeah.
But it's it's wild.
The time just keeps flying.
- Yeah.
Well you start so young.
- That's I think
that's what happens when you.
- Yeah, I'm like I got
decades under my belt now.
- I know it feels weird.
I feel weird saying like 20 years in the,
that feels weird to me too.
- Yeah.